think i knew somewhere deep down that
there was a bit of panic
but you're also you know you do what you
do especially when you're young where
you're like
you just i'm like you know
there's no problem here i can do this i
can do this and i'm gonna have to have
to do this you have no choice get up
allen yeah
you got three kids get to [ __ ] work
let's go you're right that's what
society and what everything everybody's
telling you sort of like
and you are kind of falling apart at the
same time right trying to be this man
that you
can't possibly be or are trying to be
right right so do you feel like there's
the pressure of you you're trying to be
the best dad trying to be the best uh
husband trying to do all these things
and that's what part of it was yes and
then trying to reconcile that with
reality which you know um there were
moments that i were very difficult you
know and
you know keeping my marriage together
was very difficult you know i was
you know as my career was accelerating
and i was working on bigger films with
bigger stars and um you know and then
realizing you know
not everybody that you work with cares
that you're married and you know there's
a lot of friction because uh some people
would rather you not be married and then
you're like maybe i shouldn't be married
right
you know it's very you know um uh it's a
difficult uh it's a difficult place to
be and
um
you know so there was a lot of growing
pains you know for somebody who grew up
very blue collar
um in north dakota and yeah i was born
in north dakota i was raised in illinois
in florida you know my i have a place in
florida now i live there now um
you know uh being confronted with
you know
um
you know starlets and
you know films and the press and and
what people s often you know attribute
to
uh
the celebrity like the you know the red
carpets in the picture you know and i
mean you know there's like the glitz and
glam of it all which is not all it is at
all i'm not it's a very small part of it
right um and a part of it that doesn't
matter but um you know being confronted
with that and going like oh there's this
whole other side of life that i had no
idea existed and now i'm being exposed
to it but i'm also married and i forgot
the young kids and
who i
who did i jump the gun here you know i
mean you have to die you start to second
guess yourself yeah i'd be lying if i
didn't say that you know i've been very
open with my wife about this you know
and you were enticed there was mo yeah
sure there's moments where like i don't
know if you know um i don't know if the
life i chose is the life i want right
now you know and then you so you know
and then you feel a huge amount of guilt
and shame for even thinking those
thoughts you know which
um so there was you know that was there
was sort of that thing i like under the
cauldron a little bit um but then i you
know
bizarrely
for me it was i had a very good year
like a very good year wow but it was too
it was too much you know i took on every
you know i wrote i you know i write down
my goals at the beginning of the year
put it on paper let me put it out into
the world
i want to direct the film i want to sell
this script i want to sell a manuscript
for a book i want to do and everything
that i
every i ticked every box you're making
it happen yeah dude it was a good year
and um
you know reap the rewards from that
financially you know and uh
but servicing all those monsters that i
was creating was becoming too much and
so i had to force myself into this
brainwave state for nine months i like
made myself manic to
deal with this you know so i've got
identity issues
[Music]
issues do you understand that sure i
mean i think you know
you know not like i was talking about it
every day but just knowing that there's
something behind the veil there that's
like i'm not sure who i am or what my
purpose is here in my marriage or in my
life or career
and then
i'm manic for for for far longer than i
should be to to service all these
masters
and uh and then i had the straw that i
think broke the camel's back was
i had a business partner who i had done
everything right for you know i had
uh i you know honored faithfully all our
contracts like was doing a great job
making uh successful business forces
honest
very honest and uh multiple audits by
some of the biggest auditing firms to
prove that because there were like false
allegations
when there was retribution for me
deciding to walk away but um i was
confronted with a business partner who
um gave me an ultimatum you know well
into our business dealings together like
if i didn't
provide this quid pro quo relationship
thing that she was gonna um destroy my
reputation and our businesses she didn't
care she had so much money anyway
and uh you know
you know needing being confronted with
this sense of like well
you know i know i'm not perfect and i
have issues
but when you do it all right and this is
where you end up anyway in a in like a
long drawn-out legal battle
just trying to um
you know
you know protect your reputation because
you got somebody making these false you
know i mean i had lawyers calling me up
going you're dead meat buddy and i'm
like who is this and they're like we
know that you've been buying houses with
you know bitcoin and you've been taking
stealing money from the company and
you've been buying cars jesus i'm like
what are you talking about like i've
never audited me that there's nothing
worse than being innocent or not having
done anything wrong people are accusing
using you of it that's this
this person looked at me and i said if
you don't come up to my hotel room right
now give me what i want
i'm going to call tmz and tell them that
you are you you sexually assaulted me
tried to rape me and by the time
by the time by the time you clear it up
everybody will already think that you're
that you know like it won't matter the
damage will be done
like that to my face that threat and i
was like
you you're making a huge mistake like
this is that's not i mean and you're
feeling this yeah you're feeling the
stress you're feeling the anxiety yeah
dude all that man so um so so so you
know i flew home after that conversation
and a guy lawyered up you know to
protect myself and thankfully like
nothing ever happened you know that came
of it but um but uh
you know that
coming coming out of that season of
busyness and and all that the manic
energy for far longer than we should
ever have to sustain that kind of energy
this
i you know this this crisis of like
faith and humanity
you know um
a little bit of uncertainty of like
where i should be right now and identity
crisis a little bit yeah
dude and you you came to your wife and
you told her honestly this is what i'm
feeling and this is what i'm thinking
and i don't want to ruin this marriage
but these are kind of what i came to her
and i said i think it's better if i'm
not here
really yeah and what'd she say
please don't do anything crazy
you know it was a very real question
like here meaning like if you weren't
alive yeah you were that bad you were
dark it was very i could not pull myself
out of it you know because once i once i
got settled down back in l.a
after all of it after all the dust
settled
i was like
i could i couldn't get up in the morning
like you know the things that you talk
about with depression like i could you
know only wanted to sleep all the time
it felt so foreign to me somebody with
like this zest for life and this energy
that's you know i mean this drive this
work ethic like it's it's insatiable and
to feel like i don't i can't get out of
bed
i didn't understand why i would want to
anyway and then feeling like now i'm
just a burden to my family that my kids
are seeing me like this i can't let them
see me like this this is i'm like this
shell of myself and they see me in bed
all day
it would just be better if i wasn't here
and uh wow uh yeah man and because i
know what that's like i know it's like
just waking up and going i just want to
go back to sleep i just want to lie down
yeah i don't have enough energy for the
day and that's depression huh yeah
yeah but that but that depression is a
red flag for something much deeper which
for me was about purpose and i didn't
know i so i've been open about this i've
talked about this publicly on my little
channel my you know trying to help
people who maybe have felt like this and
don't understand it hold on just a
little longer because if you do hold on
just a little longer and you felt like
this there is hope for you there's hope
for a better day where we can remember
why we're here remember who we are and
and and take time to find our purpose
and sometimes that means a big shift
sometimes a little shift um for me
it still sort of fit my understanding of
the world but i needed to make it a
choice about who i wanted to be and
what that you know the consequences of
that would be in my outward life you
know and um
i didn't know that at the time i
couldn't speak to that at the time but i
uh i went up in my attic i had a
a big house with um a you know second
story that i turned into movie sets
right and i went up in uh this movie set
that i'd shot in it it was such a weird
such it's still such a weird thing to
think about but um
and i don't know why i went up there i
just felt like the only place to do this
the best place to do this i don't know
and i i
uh i strung a green extension cord
around some rafters in my
set you know that's like there's no roof
it's a fly walls and stuff and um
and i hung myself
and you hung yourself yeah
yeah and it's still hard to think about
the fact that like i would do something
like that to myself especially with kids
but i
i now understand what it's like when
people
are like i don't understand why they
would kill themselves and i'm like i can
tell you from experience
they thought they were giving the world
a gift
that is the saddest lie that we could
tell ourselves but geez i thought that i
was doing my family and my community a
favor because i i was such a mess